yusef joseph lambert ya lo he tres
hombres se disputan el liderazgo de
haití unas horas después del asesinato
del presidente joseph primer ministro
desde abril se declaró al frente del
país anunciando el estado de sitio y
reforzando así los poderes del ejecutivo
sin embargo uno de los últimos gestos
políticos del difunto mandatario joven
el mois fue nombrar el lunes a otro
primer ministro ariel office tras el
asesinato del presidente me convertí en
la máxima autoridad legal y regular
porque había un decreto que me nombraba
pero había lo he aún no había jurado su
cargo en el momento del asesinato para
complicar aún más las cosas tampoco hay
parlamento en funciones ya que las
elecciones legislativas que debían
celebrarse a finales de 2019 se
pospusieron sin embargo el senado de
haití que actualmente cuenta con sólo un
tercio de sus 30 asignaturas habituales
nombró el viernes a joseph lambert como
presidente interino
si comes
si se hace como se está haciendo toda
esta hermosa gente llegará a un acuerdo
político que luego sería validado por
sólo el tercio del senado
el cierre mientras tanto el ministro de
elecciones mayas quien mantuvo que clu
yusef mantendría ese papel hasta que las
elecciones presidenciales se celebren el
26 de septiembre tal como estaba
previsto
enfoque al camino para que se produzca
el caos porque hay grandes grupos de
personas que no quieren que haya
elecciones
por su parte martín weale la viuda del
presidente y pidió a los ciudadanos de
su país que continúen con la batalla
liderada por su difunto esposo